now one of the most beloved stars to
have ever kicked his way across the
Silver Screen Jackie Chan first found
Hollywood success with the action comedy
Rush Hour the 1998 film paired Chan's
martial arts Savvy Hong Kong detective
with Chris Tucker's rius La cop together
Chan and Tucker St in the eighth highest
grossing movie of the year and kicked
off two sequels in the process and now a
third is on the way at the Red Sea
International Film Festival Jackie Chan
revealed that he's in talks to make Rush
Hour 4 he added that he was about to go
talk with the director about the
upcoming film although he didn't reveal
the filmmaker's identity the previous
installments in the series were all
helmed by Brett Ratner but as Ratner is
now a persona non grada in Hollywood a
new director is likely to be stepping up
to bat despite Ratner claiming he was
making Rush Hour 4 back in 2018 however
it does at least look like Tucker is
coming back rush out for that's
something I definitely will probably
drop in there because I love working
with Jackie no due date yet but it seems
Rush Hour 4 is certainly on the way